savez-vous qu'il existe un trophée de la
meilleure tarte tatin du centre Val de
Loire il a été remporté par un tour en
Jau une vingtaine de pâtissiers
professionnels et amateurs y
participaient dans les locaux de la
Villa Rabelais la cité de la gastronomie
à Tours 12 jurés ont goûté à toutes les
tartes pour les départager reportage de
Léa Turquie et Laura Chauvet
une pâte croustillante un caramel bien
doré et une odeur sucrée qui donne l'eau
à la bouche quand on parle de tarte
tatin chacun a ses petites préférences
j'aime bien qu'elle lui a un petit peu
qu'elle soit un peu brillante ça invite
un peu plus le coup de fourchette plutôt
que terme moi ce que je surtout en tant
que pétière ça va être la pâte la pâte
feuilletée qui est quand même beaucoup
plus technique pour une cuisson de
caramel ou juste vraiment la juste
couleur si c'est trop cuit au départ ça
finit le noir comme ça arrive sur
certaines qu'on a vu alors moi j'aime
bien le côté un petit peu caramélisé
mais l'harmonie des couleurs un ton un
petit peu marron brun une dégustation à
sans lécher les doigts une dizaine de
jurés sont réunis pour élire la
meilleure tarte tatin de la région en
lice des restaurateurs pâtissiers
traiteurs apprentis et même quelques
particuliers pour satisfaire le jury il
faudra marquer le plus de points
possible et sortir du loterie de
référence d'aide justement à la notation
par rapport à pour nos jurys qui vont
vraiment basé en partie sur l'esthétisme
et en partie sur du goût
une petite tarte sont en compétition
dans deux catégories différentes
traditionnelles et créatives un concours
organisé à la Villa Rabelais pour
remettre en lumière les origines de la
fameuse tarte renversée notre région
contrairement à la choucroute alsacienne
ou aux produits de la mer en Bretagne
notre région n'a pas encore finalement
de recette qui arrive à l'illustrer à
travers la France alors que finalement
quand on va dans n'importe quelle carte
de restaurant parisien on s'aperçoit que
le mot tata apparaît qu'il soit dans une
recette sucrée ou une recette salée donc
il y avait une raison de montrer que la
tatin a des origines de la région Centre
Val de Loire la médaille d'or des
professionnels revient
à la tonne Garden à Tours du côté des
étudiants c'est Cyril Jeanneau apprenti
à la boulangerie puis barré de
Chambray-lès-Tours qui remporte la
première place